And lastly, we want to add our directional light,
which is going to be our main light in our scene.
Now, for this example, we can essentially view our directional light as,
say, for example, the sun.
We will change this a little bit later as we start doing more artistic
and very specific kind of staged lighting.
But in this case, we want to replicate the sun.
So to do that, we're going to use our directional light.
And then we'll keep these settings in mind here
that we're going to change.
Let's go ahead and jump back over to our project.
All right, so from here, we're going to go to our Place Actors panel,
and I'm going to search for directional light.
We'll just drag this into our scene.
And we won't see much of an effect, and a big part of that is because
our post-processing volume is controlling that exposure.
So underneath our intensity, we're actually going to use
a more realistic value of 300 lux.
And then we're also going to go down to our mobility settings
and change this to movable, which will get rid of our big lighting area.
And then you can see if I move this light around,
you'll see we actually do have that directional light occurring.
And then there are a few other settings that have been noted here,
in particular about disabling distance field shadows
or unchecking atmospheric sunlight.
These are for more advanced topics, but in this situation,
again, if I'm actually trying to recreate the sun,
I may want to put on like light shaft occlusion, light shaft bloom.
There are other things as well that we can do within our shadows,
distance field shadows, turn those off and on.
For the purposes of this example, all we really need to be concerned about
is changing our mobility to movable, the intensity set to 300 lux,
and we should be good thereafter.
So this should get all of our lighting set up, and you can see, in fact,
we are now actually, you know, again, referencing and comparing
against our various different materials that we have in our scene.
You can see that we start to get a fairly good look at our scene,
and things are actually shaping up really well.
And then lastly, one of the other things that I do want to mention here
is you can see from this particular scene that we have set up,
we have our preview spheres with various different materials.
Of course, we have our vehicle in the middle.
And there are a couple other tools that I want to make mention real quick
as you're building out this neutralized scene.
So if I go back to our classroom underneath the calibration collection,
we have this BP calibration, which is included with the automotive materials,
and this SM color calibrator, which is a part of the core engine content.
So if I drag these into our scene, so I'll kind of move this up,
and then I'll drag this calibration into our scene,
and I'm going to go ahead and just scale this down,
just slightly lift it up and rotate it.
So the important thing to note about both of these assets is
they include some very convenient and very standardized,
various different references for building out various different lights,
coloration, et cetera.
So both of these include a Macbeth chart.
So that's what this middle color swatch is,
and these do correlate with a real world chart.
So the Macbeth chart has very specific color values, hex values, luminous values, et cetera.
So by dropping this into our scene, in particular if we look at our color gradation
or at least our luminous gradation here, we can quickly see that,
for example, in this lower right, the white cube and then the not as white cube beside it,
we can still see it, meaning that our scene is not overexposed or underexposed.
Now to show a good example of where you would want to compare
your lighting against these particular tools,
if I select our directional light and change our intensity, let's say, to something like 150,
or let's even go down something like 50,
you can see things start to get a lot darker.
And again, we can reference these specific color values to find out if we're within range or out.
And then conversely, if I change our intensity to say something like 1200,
you see it start to blow out our upper end of our values, which is again not exactly what we want.
So I'll go ahead and change this back to 300 lux,
and you see we fall well within the range that we were looking for.